I am Noah
this is your at-home bootcamp workout so
now we're gonna do a little bit of fight
conditioning a combat fight conditioning
is know I like to call it boot camp
style big part of boot camp is combat
training this sounds intimidating let's
so let's see what do you got to do for
me all right so we're gonna start it up
again three three different moves so
we're gonna start with a jump switch we
drive so you're gonna squirt your feet
up left foot is forward facing forward
45-degree angle of that back foot you're
gonna drive one knee jump okay
that's it then - burn it - burn it out
and hit our core a little bit get that
cardio conditioning up which is a very
important part of fighting you're gonna
hold a towel overhead we're gonna grab a
towel straight to high knees so thirty
seconds each move and we'll take it to
the next move we're gonna go for a back
lunge working on our balance we're gonna
take it to a kick right back to that
position me last thing we're gonna do
get a little bit more intense with it
we're gonna sprawl it out
jump up sprawl it out leave leg changes
this time 45-degree angle of the back
foot gotcha we're gonna take that again
that's the minute burnout though look at
the sprawl to the four punch combo
that's it okay and let's start it up
right there try John I want to drive
that hip in all that power is coming
right from that hip throw these up so
let's go grab that towel right away
finish the cardio portion high knees as
high as your together that's a fight
face - you might have something hidden
over that let's go right left right left
right to the next move thirty Seconds
hit it brother hit it always exhaling
that kick get that heel involved and
time let's switch it up perfect exhale
that if you want to get that girl extra
power fan it down on now last move
so the important thing about this jump
it up need leg doesn't matter which one
because we're alternating get that hip
involvement one two full full turn of
that body all that power is coming from
your hips not your arms hips hit up one
more let's go finish strong
get it's gonna be strong that's how you
finished right there
and one for good measure that's it I
went through this little combat workout
here and it started off with 30 seconds
of jump switch knees 30 seconds holding
the towel we head between those high
knees then we went into the second round
which was 30 seconds per leg of the back
lunge to front kick slash knee combo
alternating and and we finished off with
a minute or two burn out basically of
the plank sprawl into the four punch
combo you train like a badass you act
like a badass
thanks man alright make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
other fighting weight episodes